hi my name is Gabriella baldacino and I
play Morgan I'm Maya Rudolph I play
Malvina I'm Amy Adams I play Giselle I
am Adina Menzel I play Nancy I'm Jama
Maze and I play Ruby I'm Yvette Nicole
Brown and I played Rosaline in
disenchanted and we are here on BuzzFeed
to take a quiz to find out which
disenchanted character are you so let's
get started
[Music]
I'll start great how would your friends
describe you loyal Moody funny creative
kind or cunning if my friends describe
me as cunning I think they wouldn't like
me very much I'm going with loyal I'd
cut somebody for my friends that's what
I'm doing there's not one for perfect oh
that's what I call you Jama okay I'm
gonna put mine in if I have to read the
next thing out loud I need Gabby's eyes
which of these mundane situations would
be your villain origin story missing
your flight by two minutes and the next
one isn't for a full day getting cut in
line at Starbucks in the morning you
really needed your coffee being stuck
next to a loudshure for several hours
going to the movies and the people in
front of you are using their phones and
talking loudly the whole time watching
someone clip their nails in public and
no no someone telling you you look tired
I once missed my flight by two minutes
what wasn't by two minutes it was like
20 minutes and I started crying
oh it's the movie thing for me guys me
too drives me crazy clip nails and
Publix no I think that just becomes
that's not my villain story that's sort
of like why I ran to the restroom I'll
read the next one what would be most
appealing to you about living in
Suburbia dream house no dream home oh
we have my glasses Town festivals
peace and quiet cute stores cute stores
oh I can blow it up cute stores knowing
all your neighbors nothing I'm going
peace and quiet because I'm an introvert
you are it's shocking isn't it I'm an
introvert that loves people an outgoing
introvert she's the most extroverted
introvert I've ever met how many to nap
after all we need a long nap after this
choose a Disney character to go on an
adventure with is it chip from uh Beauty
and the Beast or Queen Elsa oh gosh I
know my pick
um for Frozen Princess Tiana or Maribel
Madrigal or the Genie or Ursula I'm
going with Queen Elsa I'm putting Queen
Elsa as well that's who I want to go on
an adventure with if you don't pick
Queen outside it's okay I won't no
pressure or anything well Tiana is
buried she's she is a good Adventurer
but she's in denial of her true self she
is
that bad I just well you love Robin
Williams that's okay and I also want to
ride on that carpet pick a song from
Enchanted or disenchant okay true loves
kiss happy working song
that's how you know oh perfect the magic
of andalasia or batter oh that is good I
want to sing happy working song and I
want to sing that's how you know was one
more fun than the other I like that's
how you know because it was through
Central Park which is one of my favorite
places on Earth I did not pick that one
though
I picked batter I really got to sing
really really like aggressively in that
and that's really fun and it was a joy
for us to watch YouTube perform you have
no idea and I'm picking that song
because after watching you do it it was
in my it's still in my head she's saying
that we got here today it's it's in
there I I love happy working song it's a
fun one it's a lot of words I'm I'm not
I'm just warning you and they actually
had they actually had some real rats
real Rats the only thing I wouldn't work
with is real cockroaches I do the lime
choose a celebrity to turn into a
cartoon prince or princess
Austin Bell Harry Styles lizzo Taylor
Swift Amy Poehler or Dwayne The Rock
Johnson oh these are fun choices yeah
I'm going with Amy Poehler I kind of
want to watch her have a princess moment
that would be a delight I'd also like to
see a lizzo princess
I know who I am I know who I am yeah
you're gonna be happier sorry Adina I
didn't mean to do that oh that's okay it
wasn't my song I know it wasn't your
song but it still was a reference I do
that all the time it's actually my
favorite song Wicked oh my god look what
I got Prince Edward
I've got Malvina
I got Robert Phillips I got you so I got
just
you do no you can read it for the team
yeah okay you are an eternal optimist
and you wish that life could always be a
fairy tale but sometimes that gets you
into a little bit okay A lot of trouble
you'd never intentionally hurt anyone or
act like a wicked stepmother because
your loved ones mean everything to you
but if you did you'd do anything to make
things right Bingo baby you're Prince
Edward you're charming good looking and
kind that's you you've had a lot of
growth over the years and have become
someone that friends and family can
really count on you're an ideal
Godparent and it would be anyone's wish
come true to have you in their lives
that's like the nicest thing I've ever
been told about myself you're Malvina
Monroe some call you a queen others
might say girl boss that's because
everyone especially your tight-knit
group of friends knows you're always the
one in charge in calling the shots
you're powerful and cunning you'd do
anything to stay in control which
sometimes leads to chaos to put it
nicely but underneath make the tough
facade you're definitely not quite as
wicked as you appear how scientific was
this test
okay so I got you got your Robert Phil
IP at first you might
do my classic fairy burial hero but
that's exactly what you are whether
you're rocking a suit in the big city or
literally saving lives in a fairy tale
town and there's one group of people who
know that better than anyone your family
you're the glue that holds them together
said the single Gap
I like that one though I do like that my
friends are my family so I think it's
true thank you BuzzFeed you can watch us
all in disenchanted on Disney plus we
did it come join us
bye now from Giselle bye bye
I'm coming down the hall to see you guys